and welcome to this video playing yard
but I'm going for my Queens gambit here
I think solid not going to take again on
c4 yeah that's that weird gambit line
that he plays tongue I'm sorry my voice
is a little bit strange the cold weather
taking its toll okay so see how you can
get in a check against the last guy that
I'm very curious to see hmm very early
before him okay I'm going for Bishop d7
now I'm not going to trade this Bishop
d7 rook c8 let's just drive some dry
technical chance for a change usually
hey I grab stuff against him and try to
defend leading to interesting games that
i often loose it so I'm trying something
a bit different here okay so i watch now
oopsie eight is going Queen a five or
what is he doing ok check
and so rook c8 takes things
oopsie takes on CN Bishop c8 going to be
five or something that's a bit past
seven it is a bit passive do I want to
play Bishop he ate and then kick him out
first okay Quincy five is kind of
threatening ok so maybe play differently
with a four maybe okay
yes it is slightly passive really is
and yeah I cannot go look c8 no no not
good to get the bishop back to the seven
and then regroup maybe b5 is an
interesting really cutting this off
maybe
mm-hmm so I cannot go whoopsie 87 that's
some way to get rid of this this this
annoying pressure here is e five mo
voices is this okay okay so okay is
going back but where exactly where is he
going if i go here maybe night h for
that i can go look see eight
and that's strong I guess
okay cannot go to be six to go here I
guess
okay is 94 now possible I look cheeks
you can check with the roca hmm time
warning
it's not exactly fun to play this
position yeah I really got myself until
you travel there night-night f4 maybe
for food should be six okay didn't
expect a three okay look II one is not
really a big big deal awesome in
something not something that he has to
be afraid of in any way be five is
attacked however this one okay
let's do this check oh ooh ooh that's a
big oversight now well can I still
continue here no oh and I just I just
didn't see like there's a hard hang out
that was a bad game I was really in a
passive position them so how did this
happen um okay I kept taking with the
sea porn is debatable i guess but i
didn't think that this would be so bad
k night c4 is an improvement but how did
this become so bad check now in this was
passive but it was amazingly awkward
yeah maybe I just should take with the
pawn and it's a pretty normal position
of course maybe and that surprisingly
strong Quincy five at the engine wants
to go night see for him and play this
position it gives me decent compensation
surprisingly I mean the queen is yeah
isn't as somewhat tricky spot now I
didn't think about this yeah I thought
this wouldn't be too bad but be 5 p-5
was really strong it cuts the bishop off
and really needs to an awkward position
I actually think I didn't defend this
too badly I was kind of somewhat hanging
on I mean the position is bad really bad
but I felt like that this isn't so
terrible but yeah that is pretty
terrible yeah that blunder t5 that was
just a very bad bad performance check
this is simply not helping i'm such I'm
so bad on the king in pretty pretty
disastrous game
yeah so I probably should shoot them and
take with the upon what take it in the
first place this is also possible
playing this this kind of position where
black has very decent equal adding
chances with c5 coming I don't know one
on one of the two but that the Queen c5
I really underestimated quite a bit ok
well thanks for watching